all right the boys is wrapped up season
two is wrapped up anyway we had some
laughs we had some cries we had some
uh why'd that happen i'm gonna give you
the spoiler warning right now i should
before i say the next thing
becca butcher why did it happen i
understand why it happened anyhow let's
talk about the finale
of the boys season two and it starts out
with the videos like okay if you have
a soup attack in your school what do you
do is it like ted sprague from heroes i
mention here i've referenced it so many
times in my
boys videos but i can't help it but what
if it was like ted sprague from heroes
like all right i'm just gonna go nuclear
i'm gonna attack the school that way
good thing you locked the door so the
finale basically revolves around
three things that's becca escaping and
finding butcher what's gonna happen to
becca's son believe his name's ryan
right
i'm gonna call him becca son and storm
front being exposed those are basically
the big three there are other things
that happen in this episode but if i had
to pick three things
those are the mains how did becca escape
she's just kind of like
under the sewers and through the woods
to butcher's house we go but how i don't
know how
it doesn't show how but you kind of get
the feeling she could have done that at
any time so why didn't she do that
sooner
when she still had her son before
homelander came back and wanted to play
creepy dad i thought she was gonna have
to build up her son's powers to fly her
out of there
i guess she didn't actually need to do
that they could have just walked so that
seemed like a bit of a convenience okay
so she's out she finds butcher
and butcher actually makes a deal i
always forget his name stan
edgar so butcher makes a deal with the
leader of vaad it's like okay i'm gonna
hand over
homelanders kid to you because that's
the leverage you can ever have over
homelander
i get becca and we just go away which i
gotta give props to this show
when it came down to it i didn't know if
butcher was gonna do it or not so i'll
give it that for the tension then
heinrich him lightning shows up just has
to be an [ __ ] about it which that was
an all-out throw down man camiko gets
in on it and i thought she died for a
second i was like get the come on she
didn't soups heal but her
starlight then maeve comes down which i
figured becca's kid was
going to eye laser storm front the
moment that car flipped i was like oh
okay he's gonna do it didn't know
there'd be collateral damage
called his mom yeah becca butcher she
dies and
i mean i get why though it's like she's
with butcher
so at that point if she lives butcher's
not in the show anymore or in order for
butcher to be in the show
becca has to die because at that point
butcher's not letting her go and
seems like she wants to go with butcher
you either end the boys now
or you kill becca that sucks that her
kid's gonna carry that [ __ ] that's gonna
be some trauma he goes from basically
being homeschooled
never really interacting with other
human beings to be like oh by the way i
accidentally killed my mom and now i'm
thrust into this public world i mean
he's not a public figure but he's
definitely not in
mon paw kent farm in jurassic park or
whatever that was and homelander comes
up and he is bloody
man oh man when butcher turned back on
the deal and all those
special ops dudes from vaught are there
and then homelanders shows up to that
house i was like i hope they have good
life insurance policies
at vaught for the family's sake and yeah
homelanders just
wearing it on his face which you know
that wasn't just eye laser action he got
up close and personal with some of those
guys
eye lasers don't splash like that but
that scene where homelander shows up
that intensity that's
anthony's star man that guy is in the
zone
every scene he's in he is such a good
actor he
owns the role of homeland he's intense
he's menacing and he never lost it in
season two so yeah
becca butcher is dead a storm front
she doesn't look good supe's heal so i
imagine we'll see her again even though
vaught totally disavowed her like oh we
don't want to be associated with nazi
checks then queen maeve shows up in
blackmail's homelander with that
footage of what happened on the plane
when he left everybody to die she was
like you're gonna leave butcher you're
gonna leave everybody alone
or this goes online which i do feel like
homelander had options i imagine that's
not the only copy of the video but one
of the short answers is all right use
your eye lasers and fry that phone then
the implication of what happened on that
plane when he was like don't die here
with them means she can't actually take
a hit from terminal velocity so you just
grab her fly up in the air and then just
throw her to the ground or just take her
up to the stratosphere and chuck her
into outer space
aim for the sun or you just make it easy
and laser her head i'm just saying
there's it's risk maybe the video's out
there somewhere else and she's given
some contingency like hey if i don't
come home
um upload it all that talk aside though
glad he didn't because
maeve is one of the most interesting
characters in this entire show we've
seen that build since season one
in season one it was very clear that she
started out
probably not so different from starlight
she just ended up in a place where she
feels trapped you're just at the whim of
this [ __ ] is just more powerful than
you like what can you do you can't say
no to this guy and in this season she
actually starts to go against the grain
but
not before really just running from it
just getting high all the time i'm glad
maeve has the video and i'm glad maeve
didn't die
tip of the iceberg that's all we've seen
from maeve unless she dies in the first
episode of season three
you never know what these shows she does
raise a good point but
also there is a counterpoint when she's
like yeah no one can do anything to you
because you're homelander but if this
video ever gets out no one will ever
love you again
however he did date a nazi and there's
footage of him kissing her on stage
those memes are gonna flood him for the
next 10 years at least
i feel like a train in the deep were
kind of useless this season like more
than deep than a train because a train
actually got the file exposing
stormfront for being a nazi so he
actually did something you know he ended
up being
importantly without him that wouldn't
have happened what did the deep do he
just
sat around with his fish dick in his
hand the entire time what did he do
they wanted to have them around but they
didn't know what to do with a train in
the deep so i was like all right i guess
we'll have them join this church i feel
like that
church arc in here with some sort of
character purgatory you know
some holdovers it's like a waiting room
for season three it's like we want to
have you in season three but we don't
know what to do with you in season two
so just
hang out in this church in season two
all right we'll get back to you for
season three you set for the deep
i don't think they know what to do with
that guy i don't know maybe they should
just burn him like a lamplighter
given the choice if you look at the
characters of lamplighter
and the deep in season two i was more
interested with lamplighter than the
deep so i would rather they killed the
deep
no no lamplighter's gone the thing i
really loved about this episode and
really was the long game of season two
the thing i liked is they touched on the
fact that there
is monetizable opportunity among
division and conflict if you've ever
thought like why is this company doing
that because there's money to be made
among the conflicts why doesn't the news
actually inform people what
because there's money to be made among
conflict whether it's vot
wanting to push compound v victoria
newman i believe that's her name she's
popping heads in the courtroom
so she can have her division in the
white house that keeps tabs on supes it
turns out she was the one
popping heads and it was all again so
she can get more power but i like the
fact that it showed that in
all these scenarios it's corporations
and politicians
collaborating together though they look
like they're at odds
it is still a collaboration to gain
power over people they're manipulating
perception and shaping the narrative and
if you shape the narrative
you can then control the outcome it's a
tactic driven by social media fueled by
division and
funded by the outrage economy it's
happening all the time we see it all the
time and in the end you'll either be
butcher possibly working for this new
division that's
essentially just created by someone who
manipulated someone to get more power
or you'll be huey also working for them
it's just everyone's a part of the wheel
so i felt like that point took a bit to
rear its head in this season but it
finally did and i did like seeing that
also shows why
the boys is probably a better binge than
a week to week scenario so in the end
this season
by the end i did enjoy it i felt like
there were some conveniences here and
there i didn't feel like the writing was
as smooth as tight or as
thought out as season one i don't know
it was still enjoyable but season one
was top tier season of entertainment all
right so the boys season two have you
seen it what did you think about it do
you like season one better than two or
two better than one whatever you think
comment below let me know and thank you
for watching this past week of my
halloween movie review extravaganza one
week down three weeks to go
we'll start it back up on monday and if
you haven't seen those videos yet
because
people do tell me like i didn't know you
were doing this because youtube makes
you ring the bell now
and subscribe just isn't enough i guess
if you're into horror movies check them
out
fun stuff and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you